All right. Hello, everyone.
Just sharing the screen here,
making sure everybody's admitted.
I think we've got everybody entered.
How was everybody doing today?
Hope everybody had a good weekend.
All right, so we will get to the Monday questions.
We didn't have a ton come in.
So certainly if you do have some questions,
feel free to chat them in and I will address those.
The first one that came in was a few questions.
So we'll kind of work our way through these.
First one is regarding what supplements should I take during chemo?
Will they be okay if liver enzymes are elevated liver product?
So ultimately the chemo protocol is what we would like you to do
when you are taking chemo.
So if anybody needs the chemo protocol, let us know.
I did send the chemo protocol to this person
and this person is kind of new with us.
So just kind of starting some of these initial protocols
and get in on track with incorporating our recommendations
and conventional recommendations.
So yes, there are some additional supplements
that we do recommend that you take if you are starting chemotherapy.
They are certainly not mandatory.
So it's up to you, but we have these as suggestions.
And the reason we do suggest these is because they are helpful
to all of these suggestions are helpful to allow the chemotherapy to target
those cancer cells more readily.
And then it is healthy and protective for your healthy cells.
So one of the things that we have you do is a water fast 24 hours prior
to chemo administration.
And we have talked about this before just stating that cancer cells are unstable
when there is a starvation going on.
So they really want that fuel source in order because they are so metabolically active.
So they need fuel, they want fuel.
And so when we are starving, your cancer cells are not as, you know,
they are not happy when they are starving,
whereas our healthy cells are more adaptable to that situation.
So 24 hour water fast just kind of preps those cells.
So the cancer is going to uptake that chemo right away and to the healthy cells.
You know, it's protective for the healthy cells.
Supplements that we would like you to take during chemo.
One of them is a liver supplement.
It's called liver ND.
And yes, it would be fine to take that is if the liver enzymes are elevated.
I'm sure liver enzymes are probably elevated because of the chemo therapy itself.
And I'm sure you're having blood work done and they are monitoring that.
So liver ND would be one that we would suggest you take.
You wouldn't want to take the liver ND from the administration of chemo up through that 48 hours.
After chemo because that is kind of that sweet spot where the chemotherapy is going to do what it's designed to do within that first 48 hours.
So so we don't want to be doing a lot of detoxing.
We don't want to be taking a lot of liver support supplements during that 48 hours because we want the chemotherapy to do its job and to do its work.
So you would take that liver ND.
You know, outside of that 48 hour mark.
And then another one that we suggest is called body bio PC.
So that's phosphatidal cooling supplement.
And this one is fine to take, you know, throughout chemo and that 48 hour mark.
It is protective to the cell membrane.
So the cell membrane consists of a phospholipid bilayer.
And the phosphatidal colon is necessary to maintain the integrity of that cell membrane when we're administering chemotherapy.
Your cells are being destroyed.
So the membrane of the cell is obviously destroyed in that process.
And so in order to protect, you know, healthy cells as much as possible, the body bio PC supplement is a great addition.
And then we are not doing any of the coffee animals or detoxification foot baths during again that 48 hours after chemo once that 48 hours is up.
Then you can add back in any supplements that you took out for that 48 hours.
We want to do rapid detoxing after that 48 hours to get the chemotherapy out of the system because that's when it starts to do its damage to healthy cells.
So we pull it as fast as we can.
You know, we're adding back in, you know, foot baths and coffee animals.
And so again, the details are outlined on the chemo protocol, but that is kind of in a nutshell, what it consists of.
And then next question here full spectrum CBD oil during chemo that would be fine, you can take that.
Should I run a detox rife light program at any point before during or after chemo, so I kind of just covered that so you can do the detoxing programs, you know, up until chemo administration, so the night before that would be fine.
If you're going right away in the morning to your chemotherapy session, you know, again, just don't do any of those detoxing programs from administration through that 48 hours.
We're in the bed is the light supposed to go closer to the head or under the covers by the body, so it depends on where the location of your cancer is.
So we recommend that you are placing the bulb is close to the cancer location as possible, of course, without it disrupting your sleep.
So if you have a brain tumor and, you know, then you would kind of want the bulb up by your head, but we don't want that light to be distracting you from sleep.
So a lot of times patients will put the rife bulb under the pillow, you know, if they want it up close to their head because they have a brain tumor, so putting it, you know, a little bit under the pillow, so it's not flashing, keeping you awake at night.
If you have breast cancer, then you want it as close to that breast as possible, again, without it, you know, disturbing your sleep because if you're, you know, so concerned about the placement of the bulb that it's keeping you from falling asleep or staying asleep, then that's not good.
So you don't have to be touching it, you can touch the bulb, you can snuggle it close to you, that's absolutely fine, but it can just be in the bed right next to you, but again, we do want it closer to the location of the cancer.
And it is fine for it to go under the covers that is fine how often can you do an ion detox foot bath so you can do them daily if you would like, but again, just not inside that 48 hours of chemotherapy because we don't want you to be doing a bunch of detoxing during that time, but you certainly can do them daily if you'd like and see how you feel.
You just kind of play that by ear, you don't have to do it daily, most people are using an ion pro wave program maybe three times a week, but do know that the ion pro wave programs that we've created for you that are in your folder, they are cancer related frequencies, so there's higher frequencies that we can get into the body by using the foot bath.
And so what we've created for you in your folder, the ion pro wave programs are higher, cancer fighting frequencies for your type of cancer, and then so they're not, you know, specifically geared towards detoxing again, those ones that we've created for you.
In the general, I add pro wave folder there obviously are more programs that you can run a lot of those are for detoxification, so you can run those if you're looking to do extra detoxing, you know, after your 48 hours of chemo then run some of those detoxification programs and then she asks which of the detox foot bath programs is best.
So in that general folder, there's one called clear line detoxification that's a great, you know, general detoxing program, so anything that says detoxification in it would be a great program there's not one that's best or better than the others, just any one of those detoxification programs you can try you can try liver support programs kidney programs.
Any of those would be great to run and then again the foot bath programs we have created for you they are cancer higher cancer fighting frequencies so they're not necessarily detox frequencies.
Alright, so hopefully that answers some of those questions the next question that came in related to blood pressure my blood pressure has been pretty low over the last week or so 106 over 66 is this okay it hasn't been this low for a long time seems like it has went down has gone down since we changed some of the nutrition a few weeks ago.
Okay, so blood pressure so this isn't necessarily too low yes it's a low blood pressure but generally it's not too low once we start dipping below 90 over 60 that's typically considered you know too low or you know we need to do some investigating what's going on here.
So that is not too low that is okay I guess my question would be are there any other symptoms going along with us that you're experiencing any lightheadedness or dizziness how are you feeling otherwise are you feeling sick or nauseous you know do you have blurred vision or anything are you feeling weak are you feeling faint so some of these types of questions would kind of go hand in hand with maybe.
Low blood pressure I know this person in particular has some thyroid issues going on and thyroid beds I don't know if they have changed recently I know in the beginning when she started with us.
She may have cut back on some of the thyroid meds and I think things stabilize so you know just kind of thinking along those lines of thyroid.
Is anything going on you know if you're not really having any other symptoms I would just say well you know your blood pressure is just a little lower but not too low the other thing too is people who are very thin can have a little blood pressure as well just kind of naturally so as long as you're not really experiencing any other symptoms and you're not dipping below that 90 over 60 mark then I think we are okay.
And the next question is after pneumonia and antibiotics I've come down with a yeast infection is there something that you can suggest for this so certainly diet will play a role.
You know making sure you're continuing a low sugar diet ultimately you know your microbiome is just off because of the antibiotics causing an increase in that yeast and so we need to kind of work to maintain.
That the microbiome the balance between all of the good bacteria within the gut and so taking a probiotic a high strength probiotic could be really good if you don't have one we have some you know a number of different probiotics and we have some packets that are 250 billion I believe.
I have units of probiotics so you could try that one their little packets you might want to take that you could try doing sits baths you know with some chamomile tea you know something like that you can eat plain yogurt.
plain yogurt is high in in probiotics so you can try eating foods high in probiotics so yogurt you could even try inserting some plain yogurt vaginally you could take a probiotic capsule put it in some of the plain yogurt you know kind of mix it up and then let it sit overnight to kind of activate.
The probiotics and then you could put some of that vaginally to see if that could help as well and there's supplements to Candice and forte is a supplement that can help with yeast over growth and then certainly your right machine so I don't know off the top of my head a specific name of a program for yeast infection but certainly use your right machine look through those general programs to see.
If there's anything for a yeast over growth or yeast infection and try running that as well okay next question I frequently get shooting pains in Prometheus is cancerous neck tumor sometimes it's one to three times and other times it can be one to six times per day.
Do you know why I'm having these pains so it's hard to say you know the an exact reason so I don't know for sure but certainly anytime there is tissue tissue damage you know that can lead to just some.
Strange sensations and shooting pains you know kind of zingers so anytime there is a tumor yeah there's a lot of things that are going on in that location and it could be affecting the nerves in that area giving you some of those zingers so it could be tissue degradation it could be tissue regeneration so it could be kind of a healing thing where you're getting zingers because of the healing process that's going on.
Could be related to the right machine and what you know we're stimulating by using the right therapy you know we're targeting that area we're targeting those cells we're activating the immune system trying to trigger the immune system to go to that area of the body and to take care of the cancer cells in that area so it could be part of that healing response part of the body's response to
the right frequencies themselves so I would just you know monitor you know if if it changes you know if it becomes more intense or it's more you know it changes we're you know for while it was you know the zinging pains it's now more of a sharp stabbing pain so
let us know if it changes but you know I guess it's really hard to say what it is for sure but we just need to you know kind of monitor all signs and symptoms and put it into scale with you know kind of everything that's going on to see if we can
is this positive is this negative do we need to change something what do we need to do here so to kind of assess what the protocol would be.
So hopefully that helps shed some light on that sorry it's not you know an exact answer but a lot of times we're working in this great area so there's not a lot of black and white answers.
Any other questions so these were all of the questions that came in over the weekend since Dr Connors call on Wednesday are there any other questions that you guys have that you wanted to chat in or anything over the weekend that you are thinking about or didn't have time to submit to the Zoom call.
I don't see any chats that came in I hope that everybody is having a good day it was really foggy out this morning on the drive into work it was little treacherous but it's nice bright and sunny now.
Have some beautiful fall days to look forward to all right everyone well it was a short zoom call today but hopefully you guys are getting all your questions answered thank you again for submitting your questions through the zoom platform continue to do that Dr Connors will be answering the next batch come Wednesday all right everyone you guys have a good rest of your day bye bye.